what's going on reject nation greg and
john here today we are going to watch
the shang chi trailer rise up got a lot
of people messaging me saying there's
some pretty sweet new looks in here it's
only about a minute long but very
excited for this comes out on my
birthday so best bet we're gonna be
actually supposed to be watching him
monday tell you a little bit more about
that after the reaction anyway let's get
into it
[Music]
i know that you don't like to talk about
your life
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's see this
you got some close-up shots sir oh yeah
[Music]
oh
all those white people out there
cool
cool
solid trailer saw a little tease i'm
loving all the little glimpses that
we're getting we are supposed to be
going to the premiere of shanghai this
coming monday i'm very very if it's a
marvel premiere i don't know like with
the way how the you know pandemic is
still going on and everything how
different this would be from all the
other marvel premieres i imagine it
wouldn't be as packed that's just my
guess and it would be the first marvel
premiere we were actually attending
we've been invited to like some
premieres for things before i'll be
frank i'm not the biggest fan of
premieres i've been to a few i was
ungrateful as that might sound i
personally i'm like it's so glossy and
i'm always a little bit uncomfortable
like just to be totally honest i get
like social anxiety and everything
chongqi when the first trailer came out
it really did hit me with a unique
feeling that i often hear with like
other races you know whether it be black
latino if you see like a character in a
big movie your own heritage being
represented now i'm not chinese but i'm
asian i did not
anticipate that i would be filled with
that feeling of seeing like wow that is
that's an asian guy
starring in a marvel film like this is
nuts to me it's exciting to me i'm very
much endeared to that fact i weirdly
have like some personal association to
it so like yeah i gotta gotta go to the
marvel premiere like just gotta go we'll
still be honest we'll still do our you
know review after the movie is done uh
hopefully find a spot that's not too
loud where we can shoot our review or
just watch review we'll be honest about
what our opinions are of the film itself
but already like just on a personal note
on a very personal note to see asian
representation in in the form of a mcu
film i'm very much excited for that i'm
very much championing for it and i'm
glad to see how even these little promos
are still getting so many views yeah
john would you think the trailer i
couldn't connect to it at all there's
nobody white and i don't see razer fist
is white he is and he's
terrible representation he's a villain
sean walker to him this is not right
what they're doing or white people
that's right ah we can't deviate for one
film but no i thought this was a really
fun trailer i mean you know obviously
honing in a little bit more on the
marvel humor aquafina definitely seems
like she's gonna be our cipher for this
but also then amping up some of the
action like i really got some skyfall
vibes looking at that one fight on the
scaffolding then further on like some of
the more fantastical stuff like i really
hope that that element of the movie
feels epic in scope and construction
because you know i mean marvel obviously
like you see things taking place in like
a city or something like that or even
the like fighting ring like that's very
familiar territory i know marvel can
nail but i would love to see some of
these more like ancient looking battles
take on that sort of lord of the rings
style scope where you can tell they
threw down on some sets and stuff like
that and it's not just all a big cg
animation just getting me that much more
excited to finally go and see because it
does too i mean like even though i am
not at all asian i can definitely sort
of feel the sort of energy surrounding
this movie and people's anticipation and
i'm really excited to see just a
different cultural earmark and a
different movie film style you know seep
further into the mcu so hell yeah man
one thing that i am craving a little bit
more from these trailers is more of the
emotional weight to it all as i remember
i'm thinking about like when black
panther was being promoted and how that
is kind of like similar marketing to me
you know like you're a very specific
type of culture you're you're
representing there and then at the same
time it was like you know the rap music
it's a lot of fun it's really cool but
then you watch the movie and there's
actually a lot more dramatic heft to it
than was actually presented in the
trailers i personally thought and then
here it's like yeah we're seeing a lot
more of the humor obviously when you're
showing aquafina like you said being the
the cipher to ask all the questions so
shang chi can explain everything to her
so that way we're being told what the
world is and what's going on and what
his backstory is i mean yeah she looks
really funny but i am kind of crazy i'm
hoping that this movie is more than just
light-hearted entertainment i anticipate
that they'll give a [ __ ] to actually
throw down on some really good dramatic
weighty scenes like the first trailer
gave me a little bit more of that than
kind of the little teases that we've
been getting so far i think the big
concern that is on people's minds right
now will this movie get delayed i don't
think it will get delayed in fact i
think there's a lot writing on this
movie to do well this is the first big
disney release that is not dual release
at all or only on disney plus anything
of that nature it's strictly going to be
for the theaters now we already got more
delays that have already occurred for
other films um there's rumors about
other movies that we are very much
looking forward to that might get
delayed i think a lot is riding on shang
qi right now to really be that movie to
determine
how the box office can truly be this is
a huge summer film this is a marvel
movie
so if it can perform up to the standards
closer to what it was like pre-pandemic
i don't i mean i'm sure it's not going
to do what it would have done if we
weren't in the pandemic if it can like
really destroy the box office if we can
really do a great job i think we'll be a
little bit more secure in some releases
that are expected to come out because if
not
then i expect that we'll probably get
more delays for other films especially
factoring in what the second weekend
will be like because i imagine opening
weekend for this film is gonna be huge
it'll probably outperform black widow
it'll be massive i think the real
telltale sign will actually be in the
form of the second weekend there's
always a dip there's always a drop but
if it's less than all the other movies
that have come out i think we're that's
a good determining factor here so a lot
is writing on this movie right now
because we got shaun chi we got venom
too we got eternals we have spider-man
no way home just to name a few big
movies i think bond is already delayed
so
we'll we'll see how this all turns out
in the end i'm hoping that this does
well i mean uh similar while canadian
he's also chinese sometimes it's a weird
conversation with marvel and china you
know and
a lot of rules for showing movies over
there and i think this movie is while
there's like magic on display here i i
think this movie is being released in
china i'd be surprised if it isn't yeah
maybe with the fact that you have
chinese actors in here your lead being
of chinese descent perhaps this could do
really well in china and that often is a
huge indicator for films as well you
know we'll see how this all turns out
well and i i do like the soundtrack
associated with here but guys what'd you
think about the trailer leave your
thoughts down below subscribe hit that
like button click that notification bell
hey let's do up
andrew hayes i'm throwing you into the
tournament because who's got 10 key
rings you do because you're a master
locksmith my friend think of all the
ways in which you could be a badass
fighter with a key theme to yourself
plus you could get even more out of your
10 rings by attaching stuff to them
attaching even more rings to each ring
so why stop at 10 you could have 30 or
100 rings if you wanted to but andrew
either way i hope you do it well i miss
your face but i see it every now and
again on instagram your hair is grown
out you're looking suave these days you
look kind of like a mafia guy but like
on the weekends because you never wear
suits or anything like that you always
look like pretty chillax but in your
eyes i can see you're willing to do some
unforgivable things and that's the x
factor in a world like this man so keep
it up keep being you and uh we'll catch
you next time hopefully maybe someday
even uh hang out again in person how
cool would that be that would be awesome
[Music]